Rhésus ne sait pas qu'il est devant lui
un journaliste qui se fait passer pour
un migrant on est à Toronto et Rhésus
est un passeur qui propose à des
Mexicains de quitter le Canada pour
entrer illégalement aux États-Unis
autour du lac Champlain en Montérégie à
quelques pas seulement du chemin Roxane
des voitures les conduisent dans ses
champs des terres agricoles il court
ensuite vers les États-Unis cette jeune
mère de famille mexicaine a fait le
trajet au mois de juin
[Musique]
elle a payé 6000 dollars américains en
partant du Mexique pour aller au Canada
finalement aux États-Unis
yazouri a finalement été arrêté par les
policiers américains dans les derniers
mois le nombre d'arrestations dans ce
secteur étant constant augmentation de
60 TER en mars on est passé à 178 au
mois d'août cette hausse s'explique
notamment par l'annulation en 2016 d'un
vice à obligatoire pour les Mexicains
souhaitant visiter le Canada au lieu de
faire la traversée du désert comme on
dit les gens passent de cette façon qui
est une façon beaucoup plus sécuritaire
pour eux quoique illégal évidemment le
gouvernement Trudeau nous a répondu que
les enquêtes sur ces réseaux de
clandestins sont une de leurs priorités
selon le ministre de la Sécurité
publique
Ottawa va continuer d’investir mais
compte également partager des
informations avec les Américains pour
démanteler ses réseaux à la frontière
ici romain Suez Radio-Canada Montréal